équipés de lampes frontales et d'outils
aidés de chiens renifleurs
les secouristes et les bénévoles
continue sans relâche de chercher des
survivants dans les décombres
mais le terrain est très accidenté
difficile de s'y déplacer et sous les
tonnes de béton et de matériaux des
personnes coincées qui attendent
patiemment de l'aide
quelques moments heureux dans cette
lourde tâche des gens ont pu être
extirpées sains et saufs des gravats au
moins 70 survivants rescapés selon le
gouverneur de la province
la secousse s'est produite en milieu
d'après-midi à une dizaine de kilomètres
de profondeur dans la mer egée
d'abord c'est la terre qui tremble puis
les bâtiments qui s'effondre et la
panique dans les rues mais alors que
plusieurs croient que le pire est
derrière eux voilà que la maire balaie
les littoral on a tous senti les
tremblements de la terre et comme vous
le voyez tout le monde vtc ils ont fui
et là c'est la mère qui entre dans le
monde le tsunami a généré des
inondations sur l'île grecque de samos
et sur les côtes sud ouest de la turquie
les gens ont abandonné leur véhicule et
ont fuient les côtes pour se réfugier à
l'intérieur des terres
au moins une personne serait morte noyée
en turquie plus de 12 heures après le
séisme les recherches se poursuivent
mais l'espoir lui s'amenuisent